[Music]
so
i feel a very strong
spiritual connection to what's happening
in tulsa
you know i had to be there when they
dug into the ground for the first time
to search for
black people who were killed in the 1921
tulsa race massacre
today we remember our community members
who lost their loved ones their friends
their neighbors who simply wanted a
piece
of the american dream but truly received
a nightmare
it's a significant moment in the history
of tulsa and a significant moment in the
history of the united states
the united states has been the landscape
for dozens of massacres that many people
don't know about
we in many of our cities were walking
over massacre sites people don't even
know that a massacre occurred there
nearly a hundred years ago there were
race riots and massacres across the
country
but a hundred years later there's still
racism and hatred and people are still
willing to act on that we're going to
start with these deadly police shootings
sparking outrage and loved ones of
brianna taylor grieving and outraged
and we see the country going through
this anti-racism movement
where black and white people took to the
streets shouting the slogan black lives
matter
and
demanding to be heard
but
we are the descendants of a people that
endured these atrocities
out of this past of enslavement jim crow
the 40s and 50s and 60s
our people are still standing and
they're still fighting our people have
not been defeated
this is an article i wrote about the day
that martin luther king jr met malcolm x
they met in 1964 they met only once in
their life
at the u.s capitol
in 1964 and this is a famous photo of
that meeting
so here's a story i wrote of a lilia
bundles who's the great granddaughter of
madam c j walker
one of the country's first black women
millionaires
i love telling people stories i love
that as reporters we can stop and ask
people questions there was a sign in the
the lobby of the washington post
that said afflict the comfortable
and comfort the afflicted and i walked
by that sign for
more than 30 years
and so i really believe that
my mission as a black woman is to tell
the stories
of people who might not be presented in
the newspaper
and as a black reporter i think it's so
important
that our stories be told
and telling the stories of the history
of this country
that has tried to deny black people
citizenship
[Music]
and even deny their very existence as
humans
[Music]
i've been doing this reporting a long
time writing about black history
[Music]
and then i'm astounded with the progress
that black people made just years out of
enslavement during the reconstruction
period that comes after the end of the
civil war
how they were able to establish the
black towns and universities
and
build wealth
become doctors and lawyers and
journalists and build the black press
negro in the 40 years since he was free
from slavery
has made remarkable progress
he is becoming a more and more valuable
member of the community in which he
lives
when i look at the footage of the black
families that were so prosperous in
towns like tulsa before the massacre
there's a real sense of pride
but also
there's this foreboding this
sense of knowing that soon it will all
be destroyed
so there's a sadness that comes with
that
angry mobs set scores of fires in the
predominantly black south central part
of the city
there were so many blazes the fire
department couldn't respond to all the
calls and just let some buildings burn
to the ground firemen reported people
were shooting at them and at least two
firefighters were wounded looting broke
out in many neighborhoods before police
moved in and began rounding up suspects
a lot of americans think today if they
think of the term race rat they're
thinking of
los angeles in the 90s and you know
african-american kids breaking into shoe
stores and things like that
but the truth is
that in the breadth of american history
the vast majority
of race riots were white mobs attacking
black people individuals or communities
you see there was a great migration of
southerners to the north there were
a lot of differences
you had no segregated transportation
and you could go and eat anywhere you
wanted to
during this period they're working in
the factories and setting up their own
businesses
in a relative sense they had more
freedom
however
because they started to succeed and
those communities grew that became a
point of real tension and then
eventually riots erupted
[Music]
east st louis occurred in 1917 and it
was a
horrific massacre
some historians believe it was prompted
by white workers who believed that black
men were taking jobs that they deserve
white mobs descended on black
neighborhoods pulling black people off
of street cars
beating them with their fists clubbing
them
and killing black people
indiscriminately
it was horrendous and barbaric
the naacp were so horrified by what had
happened they decided to organize a
silent march in which they were saying
wake up america you need to wake up to
this
we to america
how would you have us
as we are
for sinking need to load be there
our eyes fixed forward on a star
or gazing empty at despair
the naacp stood up and started to
organize on a level that
african americans had not done before
and really set the stage for what became
the civil rights movement
people like james walden johnson w.e du
bois
walter white recruited tens of thousands
of new members and so african americans
started to wake up and say we deserve
the same rights as every other person in
this country and we have earned it
strong willing sinews in your wings
or tightening chains about your food
[Music]
johnny get your gun get your gun get
your gun
take it on the run on the run in world
war one we have segregated military
but black people are fighting in this
war
they have gone overseas to fight
some even fought for the first right
away
[Music]
and they were very very successful there
was a group called the harlem hell
fighters
and they received accolades about their
courage and their success
[Music]
so when they come back to this country
they have a sense that they have
fought for their country died for their
country in many cases and that their
country will treat them differently
[Music]
french people had a great respect and
relation from the inaugural soldier that
was the only time that i ever felt like
a full-fledged american citizen
after a negro soldier had been
discharged of the young
some people didn't want him to wear that
american unicorn
the american white men
did everything to put you in your place
there are many levels of tension created
with the african-american veterans
returning from europe
it is felt by the african-americans that
they experienced
freedom they did not live in a
segregated society while they were
abroad
and they came back
defiant
that they had fought and died for
democracy abroad
and they were not going to accept
second-class citizenship in the united
states
we know that at the end of the first
world war there was a great deal of
white anxiety
resentment
anger
toward black people
it appears as though
any time there is a perception
that black people are rising
economically socially
there are those individuals and forces
that seek to put a stop to it
1919 the summer and fall of 1919 jump
out as by far the worst
period of that kind of violence
[Music]
red summer is a term that was coined by
james walden johnson
who was an executive secretary of the
naacp
and he called this reign of terror
red summer
because he said it best described the
blood that ran in the streets
that summer of 1919 as many as 26 cities
were the sites where these massacres and
race riots occurred
in omaha there was an allegation that a
man named william brown had raped a
white woman
he's arrested and a mob starts to form
outside of the courthouse
law enforcement said we're not going to
hand this person over and
the mob just got louder and bigger and
they started shooting into the building
they started to set fires at the
doorways
people waving american flags
i mean it was considered some sort of
patriotic act that they were attacking a
u.s courthouse
they scale the walls of the courthouse
demanding the blood of a black man
the mayor who is liberal-minded tries to
intervene and keep the mob from lynching
him they nearly tear the white mayor
apart
and finally they pull brown to the mob
and they hang him
they shoot him more than a hundred times
and then finally someone cuts a rope
his body drops to the pavement
they beat him
they spit on him
they dismember him
and then someone grabs a new rope ties
him to the back of a car and then they
pull him through the streets
and then they pour kerosene on his body
what you have to know is many of these
massacres all it took was
a rumor
and then the rumor would spread
did he commit that crime
and this is an important part of
of all of the red summer
we'll never know you know why because he
was never there was never a trial
there was this sense among white people
whether it was up in omaha nebraska or
down in mississippi
that extrajudicial killing is justified
so
this is the story that i wrote in
2018 about tulsa the headline says amid
gentrification a race massacre still
haunts
tulsa
and the story really questions um why
an investigation that was opened in 1998
was closed without physically digging
for mass graves
as a writer there comes a certain point
in the research
when you really understand the story at
a profound level
this story about the tulsa race massacre
goes to the top of the list of the
stories that i've written
in my career at the post and i feel that
i was part of that process
of helping to uncover
a piece of the truth of what happened in
the massacre
the survivors of the race massacre and
activists in tulsa
have been telling their stories for 20
years for 30 years
so i think what they do in tulsa is
incredible
i'm just adding a piece
of that
story
to the narrative
let's do a vernon enemy church
um about
math grade kind of reaction that we're
doing for tonight
but i was wondering would dr turner be
available for a live interview at 6 00
pm
um just to kind of give an update sure
let me let me check with dr turner first
all right
okay you're talking to him
oh
hey how you doing i'm sorry i just
wanted i need a good laugh
with you but i'm like i'm not going to
assume
yeah i answered my own calls
uh i have um
you know the city hall protest at 4 30
and
yeah we um
we march we're marching
here afterwards and we're doing a letter
writing campaign to the council
so depending on what time that ends i'm
sure i can be available at at 6. so i
came to toast in 2017 and
you know i thought i was just gonna be
here to
um
you know kiss babies
go to
uh uh baby showers do weddings do
baptism stuff like that you know
i really didn't come to tulsa to be like
an activist dear man gt by them and i'm
writing one to each of the council
people as you know this was done nearly
100 years ago
and to this date nothing has been done
by the city to compensate the families
nor prosecute the perpetrators
the blame of the 1921 race massacre
is at the feet of the city and those who
were in charge of the city at that time
that is a sobering fact that you not
only can
rob
burn
kill people
but you don't even want to give them the
dignity of having a proper barrier
i've been going every day at the
excavation to pray
and i talk to god about leading us
letting them know that we are looking
and i pray
that we find them
good afternoon everyone my name is
phoebe stubblefield as a forensic
anthropologist i will be looking at the
skeletal remains for many features but
for this test excavation i'll be
focusing on
are there signs of trauma if we find it
right away our
question may be answered fairly quickly
how did i feel when we first broke
ground i'm extra thankful that we're
getting to this point
and i have relatives that lost their
house in the massacre
it's the first stage of some kind of
piece
for the many tulsa that are asking
questions about what happened to these
individuals
this is that moment when tulsa said
we're coming clean we're following up
finally on our own history
[Music]
the real true healing for us as a people
is that when we do look at ourselves
and for the ancestors in particular but
for them we are not here
but for them we are not here
[Music]
so all that they endured went through
died for fought for
lived for loved for but for them we are
not here
[Music]
tulsa was
at the time of the ride called the oil
capital of the world
people poured in there from all over
to get those jobs
that the
oil industry
had available see greenwood
negros had all kinds of businesses
cafes dance halls
whatever else you want
we had our doctors
our lawyers
our undertakers all of the businessmen
were down
feeling
i am a descendant of isaac evan who is
my great grandfather
who owned the zoo lounge
just a little club
just a jew joint
my grandfather buck culbert franklin in
february 1921 moves to tulsa and
establishes a law firm with two other
attorneys
and there's a rich set of businesses in
tulsa at that time
my great-grandfather james henry was the
business manager for the tulsa star
which was the black newspaper
i think what he saw was that sense of
industry
and you did it uh independent of
anybody's interference you did it
independent of anybody's oppression and
you did it quite frankly because there
was segregation and folks had to depend
on each other
[Music]
tulsa proved that the whole idea
of white superiority was a myth was a
big
lie and prove that people with assets
and earth education could do
as well as anyone else
in similar circumstances
and that's one of the curses of the
ideology of white supremacy which is you
make an idol out of whiteness
and whiteness has to always be superior
to everybody else
and so
what does
allah do when it confronts the truth
right
it either
awakens to the truth
or
it
destroys
the truth
and continues to believe the lie
woodrow wilson is alleged to have said
that birth of a nation was like writing
history with lightning his one regret
was that it was all so true
[Music]
the showing of birth of a nation
in the white house was a love song to
the ku klux klan
that film
glorifies the clan and its role in the
country of protecting the virtues of the
white woman who was probably going to be
attacked by black men
and this is part of what continues to be
the theme if you will regarding what
happens in 1919 and
the start of these riots
[Music]
we have in washington d.c
a series of events
from june 30th 1919 to july 18 19 193 or
four
white women
reported incidents in which they were
attacked
accosted in some way
challenged
by
men who were described as black
many people say that it began
with false accusation by a white woman
that
black men had assaulted her
there are
sailors and soldiers in town from world
war one
they decide that they will defend the
virtue of this woman
they began pulling black people off of
streetcars in dc and beating them
[Music]
it is dangerous for black people to be
on the streets there are assaults by
whites on blacks on pennsylvania avenue
northwest the black man is beaten in
front of the white house
and the media coverage of what is going
on adds or compounds to the problem
we know that the washington post printed
a headline calling for the mobilization
of white mobs
and we know that other newspapers across
the country reprinted the story that ran
in the washington post during that race
riot of 1919.
we have what you you see we see two
black people no i'm not letting you walk
away with my phone
sadly we have red summer type activity
in this country now
in terms of white women complaining
about
black people who are engaged in legal
human behaviors and not sleep in that
room a young woman who's sleeping in her
dormitory lounge we need to make sure
that you belong white woman calls the
police
a family that's barbecuing in the park
charcoal grills are not allowed here a
white woman calls the police
in central park
a man is bird watching
he tells a white woman that she's not
allowed to walk her dog where she's
walking the dog and then she threatens
her i'm gonna tell them there's an
african-american man threatening my life
please tell them whatever you like
i'm being threatened by a man in the
rambo please found the cops immediately
and it's almost as if the white
population functions as deputies for the
police
you can be questioned at any time who
are you why are you here what is your
name while it's not massacres
it's a massacre of the spirit
in this editorial from 1919
the headline is the rights of the black
man
the time has come in the history of the
colored americans to protect themselves
against the cowardly attacks
of a mob no matter what its nationality
may be
the black man is loyal to his country
and his flag
and when his country fails him
fails to protect him
he means to protect himself
the washington b was a phenomenal black
owned newspaper its editor was what they
called a race man
so he used the newspaper
to advocate for justice for black people
the black newspapers performed
heroically during the red summer
and they provide an understanding of a
complex series of events that
had life or death consequences
[Music]
black veterans who had just returned
from world war one were determined to
protect their property
and their families
black people threw bricks from the tops
of houses and apartment buildings
[Music]
whites were repulsed from southwest all
together and as they came up 7th street
they met stout resistance by black
people
people firing back
they would not surrender
[Music]
and it's not until it escalates to this
level that approximately two thousand
national guard are sent in
to quash it
but ultimately what does quash it is a
rainstorm
a man named william canfield marshall
found himself in dc during the
race massacre
and he told his son thurgood marshall
what he had gone through
and thurgood marshall would say many
years later he had a hell of a time
but he would also know proudly
that even though they don't get credit
for it but negroes won
won the battle that day
they
they won that one
[Music]
the resistance seen
and showed by black people in the
nation's capital became a hallmark of
black resistance across the country
[Music]
i talked to old lamb and old limbs said
they weigh the cotton they store the
corn we only good enough to work the
roads
they run the commissary they keep the
books
we gotta be grateful for being cheated
[Music]
they make our figures turn somersets
we in the middle say thank you sir
they don't come by one
they don't come by two
but they come
by tens
before the summer of 1919 elaine was a
fairly new town
much of the land was bought in large
tracks
by plantation owners who were trying to
figure out how to eke out a profit
blacks in the region wearing servitude
to whites just as they had been during
antebellum slavery
immediately following the war the price
of cotton skyrocketed
[Music]
the crops are how the blacks were able
to peek out their survival and this gave
them a unique opportunity to make a lot
of money very very quickly
[Music]
but regardless of how much of a boom
that they produce they were never going
to be given their shares
[Music]
in september of 1919 black farmers
decided to organize
to get better prices for their crop
[Music]
late september sharecroppers are meeting
inside this church in hoops spur
they know that there might be problems
so they posted a couple centuries out
front because they were told that if
they tried to unionize there would be
trouble
the story varies as to what happens next
from my grandmother's stories there were
white men and law enforcement that
pulled up to the church that night but
they pull up and they just start
shooting
the police officers would have a
different narrative that they were fired
upon
there may have been two black veterans
who fired out
to defend those inside the church
one white man is killed
word goes out that the black people and
elaine are in an insurrection they're
uprising
whites poured in from the neighboring
counties all looking for some sense of
reprisal for the death
of the police officer that had been shot
outside of hoopsboro
word got out that there was a riot going
on in which black people were going into
white people's houses pulling them out
and killing them all of which was a lie
the local newspaper was one of the
biggest perpetuators of that lie
and that set off three days
of what i'd say is just pure carnage
murder
there is this photo from
the elaine arkansas massacre
that still haunts me
a young black woman who lived in the
lane
is shot in the neck by the white mob
her skirt is pulled up and her bare
bottom is showing directly toward the
camera there's no dignity in her death
i mean i've been doing this reporting a
long time writing about the tragedy in
black history but this particular
picture
is seared into my memory
it's a terrible thing that happened in
elaine arkansas
tell me
where we are right here this location is
called
hoops spare
where the church house
once stood
when this started it just spread to that
wildfire you know
my grandfather said white people were
coming from mississippi oklahoma they
was coming from all around just to kill
black people yes black people lived all
over right yes there were houses all
around so many so many that's not uh
in the place anymore
and so you think the the bodies are
buried
somewhere in a mass grave down there my
grandmother told me a lot of people just
got buried where they were because it
took so long kind of clear everything up
and uh they just buried them right there
you know so it's a lot of stories
i mean this land holds a lot of pain
here a lot of pain
it's still a lot of stigma a lot of
repercussions from
that massacre that happened back then
[Music]
there was an article in the arkansas
gazette
something like evaluating
the elaine
riot
my father i saw him reading the
newspaper
i looked at him and i said dad what's
wrong
and he said this person says that the
elaine riot
was fiction and i said yeah well okay
cause i'd never heard of it and this is
high school
and he said well you know i had four
uncles
who were killed down in daylight
dr johnston my great uncle had three
brothers
the johnson brothers who were
an affluent family
they were among the wealthiest blacks in
the county
the youngest brother had gone off and
fought in world war one
and had just returned
they went down south of elaine to go
hunting
which was a typical
event for brothers back in the early
1900s
they were coming out of the woods the
day after
the shooting at hoopsburg
my great uncles were not involved in any
rioting
they never made it back to helena
they were found on the side of the road
all four of them badly butchered
the mother brings the bodies to the
sheriff
and she is told that the men had shot
one of the white men and killed him
and in return the mob shot them
the mother asked
that they'd be buried in a single shaft
she maintained let them be in depth as
they were in life
this is arkansas state archive
and today we'll be looking at governor
bruff's scrapbook that highlights the
elaine massacre
just to recap this massacre is occurring
the governor of arkansas does what
he immediately goes out
with his friends loads up the car
and decides to go out and see what's
going on to do what we know that he's
participating in events while he's there
um we do not know however if he is
involved in the massacre of anyone
along the way there he maintains that
he's shot at through a cane break
and that they notice a black man running
through the field so they stop the car
and they pursue and we can actually see
photographs of them because they are
photographs of the governor there
here's the governor
and you could see him among those
individuals in the mob
these photos are astounding
this is the governor walking along in
the thickets with troops notice
uh you can see the soldiers have guns
have their rifles
[Music]
this is the only account that we have of
a governor ever hunting for black
citizens
in american history that i know of
this governor broth
calls in the military
supposedly to help ease the tensions
there
we know from survivor stories that the
black people who were hiding in the
thickets or in the mississippi river or
in the swamps
were hiding from the white mobs when
they saw the soldiers walking across the
field toward them
black people would come out of the
hiding places because they thought they
were coming to save them
and instead the soldiers would fire on
the black people who were hiding in the
thickets and in the swamps
the very help
had turned out to be
an enemy
and so they scattered
and some escaped
there were some white families who were
compassionate
and and had enough heart to
grab some blocks in and hide them they
had various ways of escaping but so many
lost their lives so many
most historians at this point have
settled on there being about 200 black
people killed we don't know that because
we have not recovered the bodies
that massacre goes on for days and
finally
ends in october of 1919.
[Music]
we know that hundreds of black people
were rounded up and arrested
in total there was 122 elaine defendants
that were convicted
and some were sentenced upward of 20
years in prison but 12 men were
convicted and sentenced to death for the
murder of a white man
12 men that were
drug away from their families thrown in
jail
tried convicted tortured
one old black man wrote that he was
whipped to nearly inches of his life
they were strapped to electric chairs
they were suffocated with some kind of
chemical and a cloth
as these white mobsters tried to elicit
confessions from them
immediately the community wants all of
them dragged out in the street and
killed the governor however maintains
that there must be order and he promises
the mob
that he will give them a trial and he
will give them an execution
the first two or three trials there was
not even any cross-examination or no
defense put on at all
from the time
the jury wasn't paneled to the time the
person was found guilty and sentenced to
die it was less than two hours
[Music]
i am descended from three of elaine 12.
it has
been a
heavy heavy weight
just um
remembering um
my ancestors and
remember what they sacrificed what they
went through they did not turn on each
other
they told their stories
they told the truth they stuck to their
stories
and um
they didn't give up
so they had to do something
if we must die
let it not be like hogs
hunted and penned in an inglorious part
while rounders bark the mad and hungry
dogs
making their mock at our cursed lot
claude mccabe wrote this form in 1919
during the summer when all these
atrocities are occurring
against black people and he's saying
basically we're gonna fight back like
men we'll face the murderers cowardly
pack
pressed to the wall
dying but fighting
back the black press plays a crucial
role in this democracy
there were reporters and columnists at
the turn of the century
who were advocating for rights for black
people for justice for black people
and ida b wells is one of the greatest
investigative journalists in history
she follows this great legacy of people
like harriet tubman who would fight for
justice
she was
fearless in a way
and not intimidated by white mobs
one of the men on death row wrote to ida
b wells
asking for her help and she responded
she traveled to arkansas
she disguised herself
and went inside the jail to collect
stories from these men who were on death
row and she published their stories
ida b wells wrote convicting and
executing the elane 12 would destroy the
economy in arkansas and pretty much
threatened that she would help
all of the sharecroppers in elaine and
in arkansas flee this state
her contribution to
helping not just the elaine 12 but
helping the families helping the
survivors telling their stories the
elaine descendants oh ida b wales her
death gratitude
her account of their case really brought
national attention to what happened in
elaine arkansas
we know that these men are then
represented by scipio jones a very
well-known attorney
he worked with other attorneys to take
the case
all the way to the u.s supreme court
the u.s supreme court essentially agreed
that the due process rights of these men
had been violated
and they were eventually freed
fighting back by the black community
that year wasn't just
in the streets it wasn't just shooting
at the mob as they come down the street
it was in the courts
as well
and those cases proved pivotal for how
we live today
anybody white or black if you're
arrested you get an impartial jury you
can't have a forced confession these are
things that
were
had to be fought for
when it was handed down the naacp hailed
it as the biggest civil rights victory
in the history of the country
and so
out of a lot of misery comes some good
i like to think
[Music]
tulsa did not happen in a vacuum
there's a direct
connective thread
from east st louis
through dc and omaha nebraska
and elaine arkansas
all the way to tulsa
the patterns of the white mob attacking
black people is the same
in each of these communities
many of the factors are the same
economic envy
the fallacy of white supremacy
the accusations that a white woman was
accosted by a black men there are
patterns in each of these massacres
the patterns
set the stage for the tulsa race
massacre of 1921.
[Music]
two years before
the 1921 race massacre
tulsa was the site of a convention
for the sons of the confederate veterans
and those
veterans
were treated like rock stars
when these veterans came into town
they
drove through greenwood
and
it said that those veterans
rebuked
the white males of that day
for
allowing
the black population
to be so successful
there's a lot of jealousy associated
with black accomplishment
there's a lot of envy associated with
black accomplishment
and the whole idea that a black person
has a certain space and place that they
should remain in
and that that should be dictated to them
by
white people
the people of greenwood
they said no to that
people who worked in service used to
come to my father's store
and tell him that their employers were
stockpiling ammunition so something was
planned
long before the outburst they were
looking
for
something to happen that could start it
off
[Music]
i was shining shoes and i was making
money hand over fists but we didn't have
the facilities there and of
course the management had arranged for
us
to use the restrooms on the fourth floor
of this building
i wasn't there so i can't verify this
information but i am told we had a boy
a young man
whose name was dick rowland
dig rolling a shoeshine boy went up to
the upper levels of the drexel building
he got on the elevator
and sometimes i had the elevator did not
settle
correctly and he stumbled coming into
the elevator and brush up against
sarah page who was the elevator operator
she hollers and he runs out now
immediately folks come to her rescue you
know they hear the damsel in distress
and
it goes from that to all of a sudden
there's an assault an attack
so the next day the tribune came out
that afternoon and told about what had
happened
and said
it looks as if we're going to have a
legend
dad heard that they were trying to lynch
a black boy down around that courthouse
so dad had an old pistol around the
house say hey people put one in his
pocket and he took off and he just hung
around there to see what was going on
so a bunch of blacks went down there and
asked if they could help protect him
and
when they went down they were armed
a bunch of whites gathered up
they gathered they gathered they
gathered and finally there was
fifteen hundred two thousand people down
black anyway
and one guy said to this black boy
said what are you doing with that gun
the boy said if i have to i'm going to
use it
so a big scuffle broke out in the shot
was fired from what i understand
then all handle broke loose as they say
first time i ever heard about the race
massacre
in tulsa in 1921 was when i was a
volunteer on my cousin's mayoral
campaign in 2002
and we were at a candidate debate and
somebody at that forum said something
about that there had been a riot in
tulsa where bombs were dropped from
airplanes onto tulsa
and i remember hearing that and thinking
that's ridiculous there's no way that
something like that happened here and i
haven't heard about it or read about it
my family history goes back to about the
1870s in tulsa
in fact my
great-great-grandfather my granddad and
then my cousin they've been mares here
i went and asked my grandfathers neither
of whom were alive at the time but their
parents were alive and were here
and they both had stories
that had been passed down to them about
it and
i i couldn't believe it at the time
that something like that happened here
in that
it had largely been covered up nobody
talked about it open
and then i go back and look at the
history and find that in the late 1990s
there was a state commission
that collected oral history
did geophysical scanning looking for
mass graves
and they identified an anomaly in
oaklawn cemetery and then the city would
not give them permission to dig
and so i remember just saying man
if i'm ever mayor we are going to follow
through on this
it should not have taken 99 years for us
to be doing this investigation but this
generation of tulsans is committed to
doing what's right
by our neighbors and to following the
truth wherever it leads us and that is
what this investigation and this test
excavation today is all about i think
it's so important to recognize there's
no way we're in a position to do this
work if you didn't have the members of
that commission back in the 90s who
collected that oral history from
survivors who are no longer with us 20
years later if they don't do that work
we're not able to find these graves in
2020. turtle's black community had no
option
for the beast on market
my father state representative don ross
now retired created the tulsa
race riot commission report it was
mainly because of so-called conspiracy
of silence
white folks didn't want to talk about
because it was an embarrassment to the
city and nobody wanted to rehash what
had happened and it became hush hush
for black folks they didn't talk about
it because those who committed the
atrocities were still around and was
threatening another right if anybody
spoke about it so for decades no one
talked about it
go ahead hi i'm eddie page chair of the
survivors committee of the oklahoma
legislative commission to study the
tulsa race ride of 1921. i was about 36
at the time
when i was asked to videotape the
testimonies of the rise of virus
many of these senior citizens were at
the age of five six 19 years of age at
the time going back in time to tell of a
ill-fated days of greenwood uh 1921.
i was studying my lesson for
exam
for the next day with washington high
school
when somebody banged on my door
my mother had gone to bed well there was
a lot of commotion around i remember
my mom was very excited about what was
going on all the noise
my dad just got in work he went back
went to sleep
and she woke him up and said i don't
think you ought to go to sleep it's too
much going on
when i was awakened by my mother i was
real frightened because she told me what
was happening and i couldn't imagine
that i just said to her and i just got
up and was real afraid and she says we
have to go out get out i said
she says the the white people are
killing the god people
the standpoint hill
they were shooting from there and we
were out in the backyard my father
came and had us to come in because the
bullets were falling out in the backyard
all of us were in the house
when we saw coming up the wall
four men with torches in their hands
these torches were brainy
when my mother saw them coming
she says you get up under the bed
while i was under the bed
one of the guys coming past the bed
stepped on my finger and as i was about
to
scream
my sister put her hand over my mouth so
i couldn't be heard
they set our house on fire and went
right straight to the curtains and set
the curtains on fire and i remember that
[Music]
bullets were reigning when i wrote
either from uh airplane or from
standpipe hill we wish you
and they
came and asked my father to use a
provocative unacceptable word n-word you
have a god he said i don't have a gun
but he said well
please don't set my house on fire
well
he and he we were fanatics with it as
soon as he left they set our house on
fire we were up and at it for sure
when we got down every telephone poles
were burning and falling and my
poor assistant was two years younger
than i am
the ken is the world on fire so i don't
think so but uh
we in deep trump
we have eyewitnesses that describe
being awakened in the middle of the
night
by loud white men being told to get out
of their homes
as they come down the stairs into their
living rooms they see their prized
possessions being stolen
their piano
their furniture
the piggy banks from the children's
savings
they came by the thousands
and
decided
first they would pillage
and they just hauled
the belongings of the black population
adults away to use for their own use
and they didn't leave anything valuable
if they could find it
these are the original photographs
the first batch of photos by the way
are the postcards
and you will notice
these are literally postcards
yes
little africa on fire tulsa race riot
june 1st 1921.
this photograph is actually taken from
the roof of the hotel tulsa
and over here you can see standpipe hill
and this is looking across northeast
across the tracks
that large batch right there is actually
greenwood and archer on fire
so what was the purpose of them creating
postcards of
greenwood burning
souvenirs
souvenirs souvenirs um the concept of
doing souvenirs of
things like lynchings
in fact what they used to do frequently
is while a lynching was occurring the
photographer would go out take a picture
run back to his lab print off copies go
back out to the crowd and start selling
them
this is so amazing to have this treasure
trove of photographs and postcards
because
as a historian you know over time
you've talked about how the story of an
event can change i
try to work from the documents as
closely as possible because while the
documents may not be initially any more
accurate than an oral statement
as a rule the documents don't change
photographs are even better
the trick with photographs is learning
how to read the photograph
and again
there are lots of pictures of mount zion
burning oh that's mount zion church
burning so were
were there um i know that black world
war one veterans um
actively
put up a resistance to defend greenwood
were they inside mount zion inside the
according to the caption
right yes they were
the notation on it claims that they were
storing ammunition there
i'm not sure that's ever actually been
proven one way or the other
they
got in the basement of
my zion church
and
as the whites would come
off of archer street
for coming up belgium and like that
but
they would
shoot they killed quite a few
white people
there are stories of people being in the
basements
of churches and having little cubby
holes where they would shoot through and
be able to um defend themselves to the
degree that they could
gun shops were invaded by the white mob
who wouldn't get guns
and that's when the skirmish started to
break out many of the fights occurred
along the railroad tracks which today we
regard as one of the dividing lines of
north and south tulsa
men of that generation
believed in
honor
and protecting your family
and we put up a valiant effort
considering the odds
um
and we we we defended as best we could
until they got the airplanes
when we left our house i was so afraid
because bullets were coming down around
us the planes were up in the
air shooting down and i could hear those
bullets falling
and all of a sudden when we got to the
track
i went over the track
and there were a lot of people
running
dodging the bullets
remember hearing the stories of
when people were trying to flee
when the onslaught of the bullets
raining down on houses and folks knew
either they were either going to be
possibly shot to death or they'd be
burned alive inside their homes they had
to decide am i going to stay in the home
and it's going to we're going to burn up
right or do we take our chances and run
out
and and possibly get shot to death
and my grandfather describes
the scene in an eyewitness account that
he has written
from my office window i could see planes
circling in midair
they grew in number and hummed and
darted and dipped low
i could hear something like hail falling
upon the top of my office building
down east archer i saw the old midway
hotel on fire
burning from its top
smoke ascended the sky in thick black
volumes and emitted all
the planes now a dozen or more in number
still hummed and darted here and there
with the agility of natural birds of the
air
i came out of my office and locked the
door and descended to the foot of the
steps the sidewalks were literally
covered with burning turpentine bombs
i knew all too well where they came from
and i knew all too well what every
burning building first caught from the
top
many people indeed deny
that tulsa was bombed from the air
the eyewitness accounts
not just from my grandfather but from
other people of airplanes
bombing the community
are proof enough for me
my mother took me to the window and had
me peer through the blinds
and she pointed up on the top of the
hill she said you see that thing up
there that's a machine gun you see the
american flag on top of it that means
your country is shooting at you
[Music]
in tulsa martial law is eventually
declared
the national guard is called in and
trucks drove through the streets of
tulsa
picking up all the black men women and
children they could find
many of the black folks were rounded up
and placed in internment camps around
the city
convention hall mcnulty park the
fairgrounds all these areas was used to
house black folks
it wasn't long before they had another
truck with some soldiers came pick this
up
put it all in the truck took it down to
uh the convention center and we didn't
see dead anymore for a couple of days
they had taken him out to this magnolia
farm
but that's where they took him
my grandfather's intern
in the
convention hall for several days
many other people african-american men
women and children are in turn
in the ballparks
and other areas where the
african-american community can be
sequestered
while the rest of the city decides what
to do with this community that they have
destroyed
that night we slept
in the fairground and the next morning
this young man came out to my
mother i remember him coming up and
he had a gun
and he asked my mother
will you keep my gun
while i go with them to help bury the
dead
well you know we didn't when he came
back didn't even ask him about that we
should have just asked him but we didn't
so while people were being held in these
camps
bodies of black people were being taken
off the streets and buried
we don't know how many people died in
the tulsa race massacre but historians
say as many as 300 black people were
killed
and oral history tells us
that black people were buried somewhere
in tulsa and mass graves
these sites included the keynes which is
near the arkansas river
the old booker t washington cemetery
and oakland which is a public cemetery
in tulsa
my
cousin and i
were going over to visit my aunt and we
walked past the cemetery we looked in
and we saw about six or eight men
digging this big hole
and scattered around in the area
was a large number maybe six or so
big wooden crates like you ship oil
field equipment in
and we were curious
you know how kids are so we walked back
and went in the gate and walked down to
where these boxes were
and opens it on one and there were three
bodies in this one
and we went over to the second
and there's four or five bodies and that
was a huge crate
i started overlooking the next crate and
the man came up and said you boy get out
of here you had no business in here
happening today in just a few hours
crews will once again search oaklawn
cemetery for 1921 tulsa race massacre
victims back in july they searched the
cemetery but did not find any human
remains
the headlines in july of 2020 were
scientists in tulsa find no human
remains in the search for mass graves
and i kept saying to editors look
people only read the headlines these
days
that's not the story the story is that
tulsa is really expanding its search
i know as a reporter from talking to
people
that that was only the tip of the
iceberg that they were going to be
looking
in other places in the city and also
other areas
of oakland cemetery
good afternoon everyone we will begin
excavating some much more discreet sites
i'm very hopeful
that we'll at least find these
individuals that are just
hidden in a otherwise well-organized
cemetery
[Music]
it's a cold morning on october 19th and
we are watching we're watching the
movements of the scientists
we're peering over the fence to look for
any reaction and emotion in their faces
now i know that the state archaeologist
had told reporters previously
that the minute the team encounters
human remains
they would put up a tarp
because
it is forbidden to photograph the dead
and i was there when we were looking
over the fence we saw a frenzy of
activity among the scientists on the
other side of the fence
we see them put up a tarp we see one of
them examine something in her hands
they're pointing to the dirt they're
pointing to the dirt
and i know i was like they have found
something the earth
had unleashed the truth in that moment
thank you all for being here this
afternoon
so today i'm here to report uh an update
at this point in time i can confirm that
we have identified the outlines of at
least 10 coffins
based on the backhoe excavation work
that we did
this constitutes a mass grave
being a part of the oversight committee
and working with the researchers and the
scientists inside the graves was very
sobering
i noticed that you can see the outlines
of the coffins they were like two by
twos and then they would line up like
dominoes
but as the trench went west we found
another coffin and another and another
coffin right after each other in the
same
burial moment
so for dimension wise there could be as
many as 30 individuals in there and so
those are the signatures of a mass grave
this is emotional
to be there in that cemetery
in this space that
until that day everyone when they would
drive by would think was just a field
and yet under that earth
all these years there have been these
graves
it was like they had found
people who had been disappeared by
history
it wasn't a movie
you know it wasn't a chapter in a book
it happened to real people
it wasn't until i got to my car i
started the engine and i'm about to
leave then it hit me
and it was just overwhelming i'm
remembering screaming out
we found them we finally found them
thank god we found them
some people say that like right back
here it's a burial site
they said
maybe it could be hundreds of bodies
buried over there why do you think they
would bury
black people here in unmarked graves
because
the things that they were doing was not
out in the open
so it's just like any other murdering
event if somebody do something they want
to dispose of their bodies quickly as
possible so they just
did what they were doing and just dumped
them into graves it's what we were told
we put a tree out there
somebody came and chopped it down
so now we're gonna put a marker out here
we're treading on bloody soil and you're
talking about entitlements
if reparations is really a word and it
has a definition
i think elaine
we are the poorest people
treading on the richest soil
and it's just a lot of horrible things
that happened
in this town and in some jason towns
you see all this cat roll up in these
fields and there's millions and millions
of dollars but black people don't own
none of it
i worked all my life and i can't buy me
a new vehicle
you know it wasn't cause i wasn't
working you know
you just you the system here is designed
against black folks
black people have been
[Music]
working
busting their butts trying to be
independent trying to build wealth for
their families and i think about all
these communities and all of our
ancestors and what they were working to
do from reconstruction until now
and it seems like every time
they were doing just what people say
they weren't doing
they came in
and they burnt it down they set it on
fire
[Music]
time and time and time again
when we came to greenwood
there was not a building standing
it was just the sound of this bricks
stones buildings blown up you just sport
on
plants
[Music]
what happens after
may 31st june 1st is that you have a
decimated community
many people flee the city
and never return
and those who try to stay and rebuild
are forced
to gather the bricks and remnants of
what were their homes and try to rebuild
on the land that they had
and the insurance companies refused to
honor
the insurance policies that people have
taken out on their homes and businesses
my great-grandmother she listed
the dishes the property the homes things
that were items in the home that were
due these things that we work for right
and someone needs to make restitution of
course she was rejected outright in the
court system my great-grandfather wasn't
able
to rebuild because all of the the monies
were no longer there
he attempted to sell the family land in
order to reopen but lost the home and
the business after many attempts and he
would leave the state of oklahoma never
to return and died angry
black people
armed with their faith and ambition
built
the most
prosperous place
not just for black people
but for any people
in this country
and what
did
this racist
white community
of tulsa
do in response
they burned it
to the ground
so every wednesday i go to city hall
um and i tell them about the people that
were killed and i tell them about the
homes that were bombed and burned and
the people that were looted and the
bodies
that were dumped in the mass graves um i
tell them that and
i called out the city of tulsa
this city
of tulsa
has never paid
reparations
to those that they kill
this city
and her law enforcement officer
the district attorney
has never filed charges
on those who committed acts of mass
terror
black lives have never married
in this city
black lives have never mattered
in this country
black activists on the ground now are
agitating that the city do all it can to
search for the mass graves and also paid
reparations for what was lost in the
1921 tulsa race massacre and they hold
the powerful and tulsa accountable they
hold their feet to the fire
a lot of folks want to leap ahead and
talk about reparations i really want us
before we get to that discussion to just
try and find these folks
and so i would like us to do that before
we move on
to you know what
uh that justice may look like at first
he said it was divisive now he's
pivoting toward
it's not time to talk about it yet
and i'm like
if that's your answer
when is the time like i mean i know
we're doing excavations but it's not
like we don't know folk were killed
after being placed in an
and i agree empire still got operations
but if they can get reparation why not
african-american
the challenge i run into is that
reparations means different things for
different people um and so for some
people
it is a cash payment from the city and i
i don't support that because i don't
think that
tolson's in 2020
should be financially
penalized
for something that happened
a century ago
but reparations for other people
mean making sure that we're doing things
today
that address
historic systemic challenges and racial
disparities that still pervade in our
city
how long do you wait how long do you
wait for justice
and uh black people have grown impatient
waiting for
justice and reparations
is part of that uh cry for justice
because there was economic loss
the economic loss was devastating there
was loss of generational wealth and
there's also generational pain will
continue
tomorrow
for truth
no testing
no peace
[Music]
a lot of people say
reparations
i use restorative justice
we need to start
with acknowledging
what has happened
and restorative justice is a you know to
me includes reconciliation and healing
i'm here to focus on land loss
there's been committees and commissions
and a lot of things that have happened
but there hasn't been a healing in the
community of elaine
share with us just the name of
one
person who you believe
has
been impacted greatly who did not die
that they clearly
represent in your view
somebody who's walking
but then
my husty uh just passed on
maybe a month ago
after 1919 she went to mississippi yeah
and she never came back would you call
your aunt's name because it is important
that the names
of those
who have
lived
[Music]
thank you
a few years ago i believe it's 2012 we
held a ceremony and we came to this very
spot and we just prayed
that the land would be healed
we thank you dear master for your
amazing grace
we thank you for these who are here
dear god to help the story be told we
ask that you would be with us give us
wisdom and knowledge
and we say thank you and we'll forever
grateful in jesus mighty name
amen amen amen amen
[Music]
today
people are starting to really look at
tulsa and people are starting to really
look at elaine but we have no idea to
this day what what really happened or
the exact number of people who were
killed
during the red summer if the white
community was controlling the situation
once the violence was over the impulse
of every community was just how did that
happen we're better than that and that
was the end of it
that was not the case in chicago
it's in chicago a hapless black man
swims by accident into the white
swimming space on lake michigan
there's a confrontation the young black
man ends up dying that leads to a riot
where many people are killed in chicago
[Music]
this enormous
vital important economic hub of the
united states was
in chaos for a week
because
the african-american community had grown
to the point where it was not only an
important economic component of the city
but also political because black people
could vote and their vote was critical
in the
in in mayors getting elected so the city
of chicago they did a very very detailed
study of the riot who was injured what
race they were where a lot of these
incidents occurred it's very specific
the negro in chicago a study of race
relations in a race riot
the commission presents
for the consideration and action of
state and local authorities the
following recommendations and
suggestions that all reports and
complaints of neglect of duty
or participation and writing by police
deputy sheriffs or militia
be promptly investigated and the
offender is promptly punished
[Music]
that the newspapers generally apply the
same standards of accuracy
fairness and sense of proportion and
publishing news about negroes as about
whites
[Music]
we urge all citizens white and negro
vigorously to oppose
all propaganda of malicious or selfish
origin
which would tend to excite race
prejudice
what immediately stands out for me is
they're calling for the end of racial
prejudice and this is 1919. and these
are still issues that we're dealing with
a hundred years later
what can you do
we think that we're so evolved and we're
better than the people in 1919 or better
than our earlier generations but the
ghosts of the problems that they were
facing are haunting us still and we need
to wrestle with those things because it
makes us a better country if we
incorporate the truth into what happened
it says
place a headstone at this site of your
victory and it's talking about we've got
to have that enduring spirit
we've got to know that beyond death
there is a destiny that we're still
pursuing and so what it means is that we
cannot let our ancestors down
[Music]
i still have hope
that the stories that are untold will be
told
i still have hope the country will give
black people the justice
and the black ancestors justice that
they
have been demanding for so many years
i cry for my people i shed the tear that
they maybe could not shed and at the
same time i recognize that in telling
the story of what happened to us
we can understand what it is that we
have come through
so this idea that we will make america
what it was no no no
we will make america where she should be
that's where we are now
[Music]
you